now this video is going to greatly help
those who are
going through
stress
and i want to make this as simple as
possible
you're just going to be drinking one cup
of this
thing i'm going to tell you
in a few minutes daily to bring down
your stress
to zero but i first want to explain
why it works now i do want to say that
reducing your stress to zero is not
healthy for a long period of time in
fact you can't
live without some stress stress is
actually healthy as long as it's not
sustained our bodies become
stronger when we put our body through
stress like exercise for example right
if you
sit on the couch no stress
did nothing you would waste away
the problem is sustained stress burns
out a lot of your organs and i want to
just go through that fairly rapidly
number one the immune system okay
stress high levels of cortisol this hpa
stands for hypothalamus pituitary
adrenal
so
when you perceive stress through your
brain
it goes through these different levels
and then it comes out as cortisol and so
now your body can start adapting to
stress with the help of cortisol so
cortisol kind of goes through these
organs and adjusts the organs to deal
with this stress
but with the immune system
it basically turns off and that makes
you very susceptible to viral infections
and all sorts of things i mean think
about what happens um when people get
stressed out a lot of times they get
sick right
and so
um stress is suppresses the immune
system so that's not a good thing
sustained stress can create atrophy to
your lymph nodes actually shrink your
lymph nodes shrink the spleen
and the thymus that's your immune system
okay so
stress is very bad for the immune system
okay so now the stomach you can actually
develop an ulcer
you can have the acid start splashing up
causing gerd there's more gastric acid
increase in the stomach that's why you
might get gastritis
the entire digestive system is
controlled by the
parasympathetic that's the
rest in digest that's the opposite of
this stress mechanism right here so
stress pretty much
turns off the digestive system try to
digest when you're under stress it just
doesn't work now as a side note stress
also depletes you of vitamin b1 calcium
potassium
and this thing right here h plus
that's a hydrogen ion now what does that
mean what does how does that relate to
anything
well when you're going through stress
you lose
the hydrogen ion
what is the hydrogen ion well you know
what you've heard of ph before right
ph that's the power of the hydrogen ion
so basically this is
an acid so when you go through stress
you're jacking up cortisol
you're losing
your acids and guess what you become
too alkaline
so you would think that stress makes you
acid no it doesn't it makes you
excessively too alkaline and the
symptoms of alkalosis are muscle
twitching
hyperventilation
cramping anxiety
interesting
now stress affects the heart by
increasing the blood pressure the heart
rate and creating a constriction of the
coronary artery stress affects the blood
sugars by turning
things into sugar okay your fat in the
sugar protein in the sugar ketones in
the sugar
and this is why
high levels of stress can even make a
person a diabetic
okay so even though you're not eating
sugar your body is producing sugar out
of other things
by having too much stress because
another name for this is a
glucocorticoid
now all this sugar that's generated is
basically making us fat so if you have
too much cortisol you start developing
fat specifically around your gut because
the liver is becoming fatty and then it
spills over into the gut so you'll have
belly fat now the tone of the muscles
become very very rigid and tight
so you get muscle spasms the lung has a
problem
when you have high levels of cortisol
you hyperventilate right
you think you're not getting enough
oxygen but you're getting too much
oxygen i did a whole video on this it's
very counter-intuitive it's very
interesting i mean think about this if
you were to hyperventilate right now
what would happen you would get too much
oxygen and you would pass out
too much oxygen
and not enough co2 actually locks up the
ability to absorb this oxygen in the
tissues
and what happens is you basically starve
of oxygen so
there's some really great data on this
that i did on a video i'll put the link
down below you can watch that later but
the point is that stress
throws off your lung
and causes an inability to breathe i
mean think about asthma think about
people during panic attacks people have
anxiety they're they're trying to get
more oxygen and that's making things
worse you should basically just breathe
through your nose calm your breath down
and then you'll get more oxygen like
really slowly
now the brain this is
the last part of this puzzle stress
both destroys certain parts of the brain
that's why it affects your sleep your
circadian rhythms with sleep but the
perception of stress
coming through the brain
that's activating the cortisol
is controlled by this neurotransmitter
called gaba okay gaba
is
like a turn off switch it's like the
brake pads
50 of all the little
synapses in your brain are a combination
of glutamate and gaba receptors okay and
only five percent
are dopamine and serotonin
so all you need to know for this example
is gaba
is very very very important in
relationship to cortisol it controls
this excessive amount of cortisol so
when people go through excessive amount
of stress over a period of time
they don't necessarily burn out the
adrenals
they're burning out this
neurotransmitter right here
so
this remedy i'm going to talk about
inhibits
gaba it blocks the enzyme that slows
down the degradation of gaba thus
increasing gaba
which turns off cortisol
so these little hormones that are coming
out of hypothalamus pituitary
down to here are all turned off when you
increase
gaba okay and that remedy is
lemon balm
[Music]
tea
that's right you wanted to start
drinking on a regular basis lemon balm
tea it's very very simple you have one
in the morning maybe one in the
afternoon maybe one a little bit later
and
this has certain phytonutrients to
increase gaba one of the big effects
that lemon balm has over your body is it
increases tranquility right that's a
really cool word tranquility what does
it mean it means peaceful serene
unshaken
unworried
so it increases your tolerance to stress
it helps you to be calm
it has properties of anti-anxiety
anti-depression
it increases and elevates your mood it
does a lot of other things but it's
really really good for reducing
cortisol so in one study lemon balm
which is in the mint family as a plant
created a full remission of anxiety in
70 percent of people who took it and it
also showed significant sleep
improvements for those people who had
insomnia and 85
of the people who took it now there's
many things you can do for stress but
lemon balm tea is one of my favorite
things it's simple you'll feel quick
effects right away it's very inexpensive
and it has a lot of additional health
benefits as well that go way beyond just
the stress reduction now if you have not
seen my video on how to do acupressure
for stress you definitely need to check
that out i put it up right here check it
out